note to the ladies do not wear mascara
and eye liners I haven't cried as much
in the past four days I have in maybe my
life I don't know that was crazy
I'm doing one more day got some meetings
lines up and I'll take you guys with
what's that ballet good morning believe
nation the time is it just before 8
o'clock
Toronto time but LA time it's 8 o'clock
I slept okay there's Nina she's getting
ready we got to go in 25 minutes or so
we're excited
this is just researching things to
expect sounds like it's gonna be a lot
of crazy
I mean camping the camera so I'll take
some pictures along the way and then
report back tonight however they want
I'm scared you're scared good you got to
do something that scares you
you're checking your makeup in this and
I already did my makeup before I woke up
before neither did my makeup and I'm
ready to go all right
exciting here we go day one we're scared
alright what's up everyone it is it's
ding what what day is it six sixty five
they five businesses I remember I filmed
nothing I feel zero on this I do
something you did yeah yeah I think okay
I think you guys dancing I feel there's
a setup it's a little bit enter Nina's
footage now
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back okay I took no video
footage it's crazy here we start our
days that we wake up to what time 7:00
something prettier then right normal
wort hi
and the conference goes until 10:30
11:30 the first day was midnight after
midnight
straight like the first day there was
not a single break no no no break until
until midnight yeah no breaks it's crazy
so I've been way behind on my emails I
didn't make a single video also I wanted
to enjoy the experience in documenting
it felt like it would take it away is a
lot of content so I'm making video now
it's our last day
well laughs take her Nina Nina goes home
tomorrow my face went on I took me I'll
take you guys and my rest of the journey
in LA but let's go around you know what
did you learn um what did I learn oh it
was outstanding and so there's a lot of
stuff wait onward limiting beliefs
don't let that inner voice over take
your oh my god what's up so the real you
your time but the truth the truth you
Wow
[Applause]
I need an exciting later that nice it's
overwhelming but it's good it's active
good there are a lot of stuff but you
won't expect to take from this event I
was crying so much that but I am my own
my my mascara and my either off much
over my page notes to the ladies do not
wear mascara and eyeliner you get water
to funds naughty notes the latest
there's waterproof version yeah okay
I know this I'm putting lemon on my cell
we're eating we all got salad part of
the end is they challenge you to do a 10
day challenge of basically healthy
eating of know what can we have no
caffeine no cost no no caffeine no
coffee no dairy yeah
Oh sugars no meat no meat and we're not
and we're also not doing anything with
flour so and really lose chops in ten
days but without salad here's my news
Nina's and and there's lilies which is a
good segue over to Lily how was your
experience Lily it was outstanding it
was a really good really good the thing
that I actually really learned about
myself is I was making up all these
stories in my head I was letting it
control me I was nobody wanted to listen
to my boy people didn't want to hear my
message nobody cares
all that stuff and I realized it helped
me back from doing a lot of things I
wanted to launch a YouTube video of
channel which I didn't do because I'm
with the old lady wants to hear what I
have to say I have nothing important to
say I don't do well in my snapchat
videos because nobody wants to say no
nobody wants to know what I have to say
but more importantly I don't help people
who I think could do so much better
because I assume they don't want to
and as a result I allow them to be in
their state and their situation and I
just watched from the sidelines
so no more say I have something to say
and what it is I want to say is that I
believe that every single person have
the power within them to be
extraordinary and that's my message to
everybody and that's what I want to say
whoo deep in the dark there we got Alex
playing the piano
Alex yeah I'm zooming in on you oh he's
coming out well this is Alex you guys
know Alex what did you take away what
did you learn what do you want to tell
my GG to the center story all right so
what I learned there's a lot there's a
ton or no ah no what's that I believe I
did it so whatever I lost my voice many
multiple times but it doesn't stop me
from going I'm going full out and geez I
I became aware how many limiting beliefs
I have and how how I've never I've never
really been aware of myself
it's amazing to say but just in the last
day right at the end
we're supposed to have this conversation
with our teacher self or ourselves and
just recognize ourselves and I've never
really done that and it made me super
emotional I started crying I have never
talked to myself and been proud of
myself I'm finding that out as I'm
continuously growing up earlier as I'm
trying to be a great role model as I'm
trying to build something amazing and
have a place take place for people I'm
really hard on myself and I think that
there should be a fine balance between
not being satisfied and wanting to grow
but not feeling like a failure and so
meaning one of the things that was an
issue a lot was I've already had trouble
receiving compliments from people
everything will get a compliment in my
mind I would be like well I'm still
procrastinating all these bad things and
I don't
I feel ashamed even you know that there
even though they're sharing their love
and so one of the things that came out
for me was I deserve to be proud there's
a lot of things that I've accomplished
as a lot of particulars that I went
through it's hard to realize that that I
thought so little of myself and so that
was one of the things that I realized I
am there's a bunch of other things like
I'm quitting smoking that's another
thing one of the biggest focuses I for
me on these four days was you need to
put emotion into whatever you want to
accomplish
except that motivation is not going to
carry through motivation you know start
look like alright I want to go to the
gym I'm going to wake up I'm going to
three days you start to do it which has
been a problem of mine but you drop out
so there's a part of like putting
emotion to everything that you do it's
not just like oh I got to go to the gym
all I thought I'd be that's all I gotta
do and it's like it's anger and angst
and discomfort and hold my whole body
right now it's like crumbling inside so
being aware that I'm catching yourself
and catching me the language that you
use and then from there seeing the
vision of you already accomplishing
those things which I've never really
done like I want to get fit and whatever
that means to me so where that I have to
bring a clear pin this is what it means
for me I decide you know actually I
realized that I wanted I when I think
about fitness
I want to have more energy I want to
have more energy myself I want to be
tired during the day I don't want to
thank Matt for for me to want to do
something to make a big life change like
the smoking or whatever I need to have
enough emotion I need to heat it enough
I need to have enough angst in it to be
attractive I'm putting this for myself
on cam making this change for myself
that so it's funny that realizing that
there's there's that level of pain that
you need to experience and there's the
level of discomfort you need to feel in
order to make a change thing I read in
this event you can induce that just as
much as I can make myself happy to go I
suppose you get it right
and also bring it down under control of
my body and you can create these
emotions if you want to make change so
if you feel like you know what I'm not
happy with my but I'm not happy with it
you start to go to the gym you know
January news resolution wherever oh I
started going to eat drop out you hate
yourself in the HSL when you to eat more
and whatever this is whatever side
everybody have their own cycles I have
my cycles it's being like you know what
this is not enough now let me picture
what the worst-case scenarios are it's
five to ten years if I continue doing
this
what's my life going to be like what are
talented and look am I then if you have
to end respect feel the painful and
you're like geez you know excuse me what
you know just you know like in five ten
years right maybe you know maybe your
loved one left you you're just being too
bottomless is not way to experience
things you're bound with is you're not
having your premiere you're coming home
and all your families will love you very
much your friends your whatever yours
your next-door neighbor whoever cares
about you and your life and they're
seeing you unhappy and you start to suck
them at it and they expect to pull back
in five again you do you imagine seven
being left alone is that enough to make
a change in your life and so for me
there's a bunch of moments where I've
experienced deep emotion you know just
crime from my soul just being in
discomfort and pain but it was a good
thing because I felt in the light at the
end
Tony pointed this out he mentioned that
he ain't being called a motivational
speaker motivation is not enough you
need to create plans you need to create
strategies you need to break bad
behaviors you need to break break those
things that you fall into patterns of so
it's like you coming home you grabbing a
beer and every time you think of coming
home as if you opening that fridge or
you grab that beer you got to cut those
bobbies you gotta cut those patterns out
whatever it's hitting the snooze button
and you're sleeping in like whatever
so emotion is important that to give you
enough pain to make the change and then
you've got to create a plan without
creative strategy I hate this thing why
do I wanna change wasn't important okay
how do I make it and accept that you're
not going to necessarily always wake up
every morning good all right I've got
what to Jimbo but if you focus to focus
on the emotion of why my DS where my
headaches
yourself down there you see yourself in
that sixth set and fire dangers you're
celebrating with your friends and you're
happy and you are that helps or whatever
it is that you want then that can be
enough an incredible adventure it's
funny I think even if you're not
open-minded and you go to it you get
sucked into the energy get sucked into
the just the raw power of the event I
just be open-minded and go with a sense
of wonder and curiosity and whatever
happens at the end you know I'm sure
that you know the team when they were
talking about the things that they
learned it's all a little bit different
so interpretations and so whatever you
learn will be completely different for a
while I'm saying right now but yeah it's
something you don't really want to miss
out on something that's gonna you know I
wanted to change your life that's one of
the things they're talking about that
you grow can't you change you just bring
out the beauty inside and bring out the
happiness inside you and you believe if
you deserve it right
so I'm honest it you're gonna go there
and you're gonna get you know change but
you're going to grow and I think if you
ever want to put your life and most
importantly you gotta invest in yourself
and so this event blew me awake blew me
away and I'm really grateful for that I
would come back to that next year and
I'll bring my family my brother I bring
my fiance Rosanna just forget to go
because they're not perfect not about
that but it's just so it's so
overwhelming and beautiful that just
being around that is isn't just worth it
in itself do you come back next year
it'll be with resent of your wife yeah
and we'll be on the exam
oh thank you I'm getting what we're
getting married on December gaming
September
they're planning on even maybe Adams
gonna pay for the honeymoon I don't know
disgustedly Edwin is out as well what
did you think I'd own what did you learn
what are you taking away I think the
energy levels that it's expected of
biggest thing I'm taking away
emotionally have gone up and down a lot
physically I can't even have that much
energy I think most of its knowing about
a standard it now and how low we were
before working oh yeah that's the
biggest thing of things so what did I
learn what did I learn from this so I
came to this because we've got a lot of
content on a lot of different successful
people and I was never really interested
in going to see any but them any of them
live but I felt with Tony there would be
just an experience I told these guys
that earlier but you know as much as I
love garyvee or 80 speakers I've seen
their full events and I don't feel like
the vibe is that amazing they need to be
there versus we will just watch video
and I wanted to see if Tony would be
different because I've consumed a lot of
Tony content a lot of the stuff that he
talked about the continent he heard
before and so I wasn't taking I wasn't
filling up the notebook but I wanted to
experience it and there's also a lot
that you are not ready for ah when you
first go active no matter what you think
is gonna happen it's gonna get crazier I
haven't cried as much in the past four
days I have in maybe my life I don't
know that that was crazy both happy
crying and sad crying and you can't
really explain that you got to show up
and do it one thing that I had learned
that was really interesting for me was
the impact of my parents and there are
my wall at my office and believe came
from them they always told me I was at
this truly Carmichael I could do
anything I wanted and that's why they're
up there and the source of belief
attempt to but one interesting came out
where I realized that the need to do
something important and
drive that make a difference also comes
to my mom one of my earlier memories I
was like 8 years old and I created this
little family newspaper and it said I
was going to make a newspaper for the
rambling because we always got the try
to start delivering I know I want our
own family newspaper and I interviewed
my mom and I asked her why she wanted to
do what she wanted to do so she was a
lawyer and I asked her why did you want
to be a lawyer and she corrected me you
know 8 year old Evan and said I don't
want to be just a lawyer I want to be a
constitutional lawyer and she said that
she want to be a constitutional lawyer
because those are the people who changed
the laws they were the ones who let them
wrote the new laws and not just living
within the law system but creating new
better and more fair or just laws and
that's what she wanted to do and I
remember thinking yeah like that I want
to do something important to I want to
have an impact you know he's looking
thing and I just realized this weekend
and that's kind of the source of me
wanting to do a lot of big things I'm
not just not just believing people but
do it in a big way so I'm going to try
to keep up and firing one of those if I
can find that old copy of that newspaper
that we include cool I didn't I'm not
really memento I threw away most of my
stuff I didn't really not really have
deep the passion to it and I hope I
didn't throw that away
so we'll see these guys are leaving
tomorrow do you know what I just noticed
what did you know everyone's still
wearing the tag we are noticing
attending nice Alex I'm really leave one
tomorrow
everywhere I am are those it because it
supplies up seven right now and then
Lena and that one are leaving when are
you leaving
um - ah you know uh so you get over 45
yeah we have to leave here alone - good
I'm doing one more day got some meetings
lined up and I'll take you guys with
[Music]
it's past midnight which is actually
3:00 a.m. throttle time we had some
awesome conversations Alex and Lily went
to bed already they have to wake up
really early they're going to get up in
a couple hours actually have their
flight so you know I'm gonna hit the bed
and start the next day good morning good
morning good morning good morning good
morning we had our morning routine which
we shook it up today we woke up to
Gerdes right lunes
a minute of loons then we did a party
song party song and dance for three
minutes
and then we did yeah okay oh right no
then we woke up to the huh sure my
mother's in there and brush your teeth
and then we danced and then we did
gratitude songs so it's good was our
test a new morning routine experiment
started today ed wait how we doing today
frankly I'm doing great Oh ed when I'm
Lily Lily Wow anyone I knew that is
Edwin and Lily being together everything
I do know Nina are going home together
I'm saying one more day they're going to
uber to the airport I'm going to / to
Beverly Hills and we're all gonna have
an amazing day alright so I'm here in
Beverly Hills I'm outside the offices of
imagine entertainment behind me and I'm
meeting at 11:15 the co-founder Brian
Grazer he reached out to me a while ago
and today turn LA I'd like to meet you I
don't really know what the context is
just he likes meeting interesting people
and so I was picked but I'm excited to
meet him so he confronted the matching
entertainment they've won all sorts of
awards he was named Time magazine's one
of the most influential people and yeah
super pumped to see him but I've got two
hours to burn until then so I'm going to
go get some breakfast which is gonna be
hard because
can't really hide most of the sewers I
usually eat on this 10-day thing that
I'm on so we'll see maybe a banana
banana some breakfast
here we go so I'm walking on the street
in Beverly Hills I need sunglasses right
for the first time first day really
crazy hot in Brighton LA this trip I
love it walking down the street come
across this place pavilions grocery
store I've got to get some breakfast and
maybe load up for the day here we go all
right done you guys want to see what I
bought I've got a veggie tray I've got
roasted insulted mixed nut they have
thing of bananas so I'm going to eat our
cernium it's really laughing at this
point of my product collection but it's
healthy the six is diet and I'm going to
enjoy it so I decided to stop off at a
Pete's coffee I told Nina she freaked
out it's not coffee it's herbal tea
Africa rooibos something's actually
pretty good got some work done ate my
veggies and now it's time to go meet mr.
Brian Grazer and see what he wants to
talk about I'm excited
all right well that was fun we chatted
for an hour which was seem to go really
quickly he's a pretty cool guy pretty
chill I didn't even know why we're
meeting and he has an interesting story
where he likes to find people that he
finds interesting and have conversations
with them and so he just wanted to meet
with me and and what he said was he
loved the top ten rules videos that we
put together
he had a request for one to add to the
list so we're going to be making one for
him maybe one for his son too which
would be interesting
he just wants another story why I
started it his favorite one was Bruce
Lee which is interesting it's been a
while since we did anything on Bruce and
super cool good to know that the videos
that we watched it's always great to see
people loving the videos and having
an impact by watching them and looking
forward to new ones coming out so stay
tuned for his request of a top 10 and
now it's why I got 45 minutes to meet
with Lewis house
he's another fellow youtuber and he's
the podcaster I know my channel while
ago and that's it I'm still feeling full
from those vegetables so pretty good
sticking to the diet so far they - yeah
[Music]
alright
somewhat lose this place let's do it
what is up everyone Lewis house here
very excited about this interview
we've got Evan Carmichael in the house
I'm good man was the right hand to left
everybody left make it all better
alright just thought out that was a fun
session Lewis's second hangout ever the
last times it was three or four years
ago so it's good I shouldn't had to do
it we had some live questions great
audience and great guy he's barely
coming to Toronto some point soon
September something like that so we'll
give you plan something else when the
when he comes up so I'm going to head
back to Beverly Hills it's at the coffee
shop get a little bit of work done and
then prepare to meet some fans I love
meeting fades when I travel so we'll see
who shows up take a video and some
tongue
what's up that way so we met the fan and
before I wrap not the one of the pot
around the camera they're going to
introduce themselves what they do and
what their one word is he's going for
instance parking today
I'm Brian I'm an investor and my one
word is invest hi i'm elaine lau and my
company is excessive tea eco-friendly
t-shirts and my word is belief hi I'm
Armand I'm the founder of swallows my
one word is persistence hi my name is ed
Reyes
I'm 2015 nominee for Man of the Year
from female employment society my one
word is hero hashtag I'm a hero
be a hero hello my name is kanesha
chosen culture I'm a life coach also
with paper group and my one word is
wrong so believe nation is Devon Church
of Oberto mom home on my actor my one
word I'm still working hi I'm Skyler
Ojeda I'm a writer and I would say my
one word is also love hi my name is
Jonathan choo and I work at Disney
Imagineering
and I also started a company called
choose joy based off of our last name so
my one word is hope
hello I'm Mandy q also hope thunder huge
joy and my one word is expression hi I'm
Selma Saunders I am an owner of Thousand
Oaks Fit Body Boot Camp and my one word
is flourish I hate Maryland my word
perseverance yeah all right la now we're
gonna get back to top all right that was
a lot of fun it's always so humbling to
meet the fans this is a really good
group and I love the LA fans that was a
really good group people showed up we
had a great time answered a lot of
questions got to know some new
entrepreneurs people Joe from from quite
a distance some of them to get there and
it's uh it's humbling
I started at four four that's four first
person came at four what time is it
there
eight four hours one of the things that
I find is I get more energy with time of
saying how like in the beginning I still
have energy it's good to meet people and
then it like it picks up I get my energy
and now I'm on fire and and then I'm
going to go home and crash at some point
but just an amazing experience guys are
awesome and looking forward to coming
back again one day see how it goes I'm
going to head to the grocery store again
that last place that I was at apparently
has a lot of good feedback and good
reviews so I'm going to see what else I
can find at home see what Nina's up to
catch up on work and then get ready to
fly back to Toronto alright finally back
had a bit of a chaotic episode there my
visa got cut off
I didn't call visa to let them know was
coming to the US and they cut me off so
I had to figure out a way to call in and
get fixed but look at this here's what I
bought I bought a green drink keep on my
diet I bought some more nuts for
tomorrow
I bought one giant avocado I bought
another veggie tray that I can eat right
now and Nina's going to love that all
right boy green beans and onions
epithermal mushrooms onions and
mushrooms that I'm going to cook we did
zero cooking this entire time every meal
was eaten at zero cooking so I'm going
to make the first cook meal of this chip
here I go okay so I burned these things
are supposed to cook pretty badly added
some water to it and we'll see
I miss Nina for many reasons
[Music]
I'm going to relax eat my food watching
episode of billions because Nina doesn't
like it so I have a chance to weselton
here at security for bed wake up
tomorrow morning and head back home
woo I mix some avocado in with it I just
got that side
[Music]
good night good morning good morning
good morning it's the last day
I am excited I get to go home with the
see Nina last night was interesting it's
a I'm a bit lonely which is interesting
it's an interesting different feeling I
think from having all of the intense
experiences over the past number of days
especially with Nina have a night just
be by myself in the morning by myself
I really really miss Nina I want to get
by I mean I always miss Nina want to go
away but I actually feel lonely miss
planet we do last night I fell asleep I
stayed up late watching episodes of
billions where I was supposed to work I
wanted to work but I ended up staying up
watching episodes a billion so when I'm
lonely I bed on TV
apparently interesting anyway I'm going
to get my uber head to the airport I go
home and see Hina
[Music]
all right I'm done whoo got mashing the
plane fighting the headache from all the
turbulence and up and down but it's good
to be back
I'm excited let's go seeing that hey I'm
happy to see the way okay
well thank you guys for joining us on
another chip no more chips or a while
milords Angela really yeah
Mina's going on a trip by yourself maybe
we'll talk to myself
we'll talk too much everything evan is
done traveling for a while there's a
file like two years
yeah right you don't know no okay it was
fun though it was a good chip
Boadicea check we learned a lot missing
rich people under think Japan escapees
alive in fact which I'm back we're back
together
comfortable I keep your name e- alright
here's some food to thank you guys for
joining us and you to believe much less
and whatever you want for it I will see
you soon